smilla hundred a Salaam alaikum peace be
unto you thank you for tuning in to the
D show we got a special guest all the
way from Sydney Australia when we come
back here on the D show don't go
anywhere this is the this is the
assalamu alaykum rahmatullah may the
peace mercy and blessings of the
almighty crater be with you shake
shouting Suleiman how are you I'm
hamdulillah salam alikum walaikum
assalaam dr. Carter thank you for
joining us all the way from Australia
yes Sydney Australia see how far is that
from melbourn at 1,000 kilometers
mashallah house down how's the weather
down there and from the LA we're
finishing from somehow we are going into
winter nails it's getting a bit cold we
see a lot of kangaroo fighting going on
have you ever seen why any of these yes
sink anger is in nothingness it'll
obviously once you leave the city is
very common so so tell us we also see a
lot of people and the mainstream news
there in Australia many people are
coming to Islam are you witnessing this
and hamdulillah hamdulillah we see many
new Muslims in arms a lot of non Muslims
entering Islam and there's a number of
new Muslims a particular in my center is
hosting one of the largest congregations
of near Muslims were averaged about 2 to
3 p-4 a week 2 to 3 people are weak
embracing Islam and the handle oh that's
well all of allah azzawajal and this
shows that the more attacks there is on
this love the more people are becoming
more vigilant than awareness now now
tell us you said something in Arabic and
the Dean show is really known for
simplifying things so you said an Arabic
word you said Allah
we have a lot of not yet Muslims out
there who are tuning it and maybe they
tune in for the first time and they're
hearing this Arabic word alone when you
say Allah when we say Allah what do we
actually mean women Allah as God known
as the English with the Almighty God the
one that we surrender and wish is our
Creator I will make our master our Lord
the one that has wrought upon us the one
the creditors from the beginning which
he has the beginning has the end and
that's what the word a lot means Allah
is the only one no one is like him no
one looks like a no one resembles him he
is above his creation and that's why the
word a lot of means so much as much as
we know of it the reality of it is
greater than what we really know that's
amazing to see because we have so many
people here acknowledging what's in
their very nature that there is a
creator and that creators want and alone
where the ax worship and that is defined
and obviously this word Allah it doesn't
resonate now that people are moving away
from worshiping men money the creation
to worshiping the crater and that's
amazing we're seeing it we're talking to
you all the way from Australia and
you're seeing that over there we're
seeing that here what's so unique about
Islam that people are running to it even
with all the negative stereotypes what's
a unique about Islam brother Islam is a
way of life the reality is we live in
life and the reality is many of us that
know how to live life in their life and
that's why you find their life many of
the times is miserable there's a sadness
depression distress even though they
might have a lot of money a lot of Fame
a lot of prestige alarm influence and
power but the truth is and the realities
and if you speak to those people with a
lot of money and fame and power and
prestige and influence out Soviet are
not happy that'll either haven't taste
the essence of white but the moment they
can make themselves to the creator and
the maker they start realizing that
there is something greater threat to
life than just worshiping money or
trying to end money or trying to earn
you know influencer acquire their fame
and so on and that's why the moment you
surrender yourself to lots of Hannah
Montana and follow the guidance of Allah
Georgia you start tasting the reality of
her
you start tasting the reality of why you
really live in this world because it's a
very simple question that we've managed
to figure out about everything around us
except our souls what's the purpose of
the existence of this object what's the
purpose of existence of this thing but
then it comes to myself what's the
purpose of my existence and then it
becomes a very complex question too many
people they out of Islam well a lots of
Hannah Tyler makes it very clear to us
the purpose of our existence is to
worship Allah and believe me my brother
the worst thing that you could ever do
to you so it's not to figure out why you
exist if you figure out what everything
around it exists why you don't even know
why you so exist and then you start
realizing than you know what what am I
needful and that's why if he doesn't
know your purpose of martini don't know
where you live here you don't even like
Olivia and that's why a lot of Hannah
tireless in the only Canaan through our
beloved prophet mohamed salah salem to
answer these simple questions why do you
exist and the moment you find out why
you exist then you start looking into
life from a very very different angle
and a different way and that's why you
start realizing and you start tasting
the beauty of life from the moment he
start worshiping a Muslim Hannah Montana
we know that Jesus peace be upon him he
was sent by God he ate slept prayed to
God and this would obviously you know
anyone using their common sense this
would prove that he was indeed a
messenger god but now somebody we had
recently on the Twitter they said that
they were told personally he said I was
told personally I was his son I respect
your faith but I believe him first
meaning God now this is not the first
time and anybody who's been in the dowel
field people say look I've seen God
Jesus came to me in a dream told me told
me these things so when you come up with
lot with a lot of times you want to
dismiss it but how would you ask that
have someone told you look God came to
me personally and told me these things
now see Allah Allah Allah from the
beetle Islam Islam is a natural religion
which means it corresponds to your
natural instinct and also a very common
sense religion it doesn't make sense
that God Himself the God himself has a
son because if son if Jesus is the Son
of God then
is God had began the Sun that means this
son has a beginning which does not
comply on God that God has a beginning
he cannot worship someone that has a
beginning because if someone has a
beginning that someone that beginning
and the concept that in a Christians
believe in that Jesus is the Son of God
well okay what makes him to be God and
he's worshiping another god I could God
worship another god and the reality is
we experience a lot of Christians along
very but honest I really feel very sorry
for this particular demon ation and
denominational people because once you
asked them once Jesus tea and then they
can I even give you a straight answer
sometimes the tree his godson country is
the son of God Allah sometime tutoria is
a prophet and the messenger of god then
that makes it very impossible either
because when he asked them to him was
Jesus worship and then they say he was
worshipping God then what would God
really need to worship God that's
something that's rejected common sense
and why would God need to have a son and
that somebody inner and what why would
God even sacrifices answer these
questions at the end of the day deep
inside your common sense and intellect
rejects the concept to believe that God
has a son oh god worshipped God or God
sacrifices God at the end of the day
Islam is very simple we believe a lot in
a most panel Tyler is that only and 10
multi God and that's why we find your
natural instinct corresponds to that and
accepts that same easy it's like when i
say to you one plus one equals two my
vittoria one plus one equals five then
you start realizing that it is something
in your monticello going to say that's
not accepted so one that's it leave it
alone or additives or preservatives just
one guy that's it one God's very simple
very easy and every single human being
will realize that's what the natural
instinct accepts nothing else we're
going to take a break and be right back
with more of our special guests all the
way from Australia here and Dean show
take that simple step that you ask your
maker to guide you that he'll guide you
yes I advise this a lot for people
researching put your head on the floor
and in the in the state of profession
like all the prophets good and ask the
creator of the universe to show you the
way to guide you to the straight path
and someone who sincerely ask the guy de
sao paulo the foundation your son that's
it back here on the Dean she'll tell a
shake do our what's this abbreviated
when you say from Australia they copy
from Australia ah geez what's Aussie ok
oz is like another abbreviation or
nickname to those trainings Ozzy's like
you know the Americans maybe the call of
Americans of the manor of the name but
Australians are learned to be called as
Ozzie's house he's beautiful ok tell us
now can you describe to us ok we cleared
that up without any ambiguity Jesus
peace be upon him he called people to
worship not himself but the One God
Abraham he was neither a Jew or
Christian but he was one who submitted
to the will of God cleared up Moses same
thing last two final mr. problem how a
peace be upon him the alcohol people to
worship not themselves not Saints not
idols icons sticks stones of bone but
just the one God and he also came with
glad tidings obviously you know that if
you obey god you're going to get to
paradise but if you follow your lusts
and desires you look at heedless life
you forget about your responsibilities
and your purpose the Hellfire so briefly
can you describe to us this beautiful
place of paradise so people get a little
more motivated just in short and then
also then we'll talk about the up the
hell fire a little bit can you go ahead
and start with the Paradise please is
brother ilias respect before that one of
the purposes of lord allah subhan allah
tala had made it very clear to us as
Muslims that there's another world after
this world and it's from the Justice of
Allah and once again it is from the idol
and the Justice of Allah that plane this
world leave the different lives people
here by Allah be with the server
people the good people do bad its
injustice that at the end of the day the
good people and the bad people end up in
one hole and there is no accountability
there is no judgment and that's why in
the hereafter there is accountability
and judgmental Eliza Widger will judge
the righteous people should enter the
paradise as a reward and America that
the unrighteous or the umpires people
should be punished in the hole fire for
their bed scenes and good day ever for
the bed scenes and bad deeds said the
righteous people shall enter somewhere
where it's called a paradise legenda
mentors as the general tenor in Arabic
means a beautiful place with beautiful
gardens the paradise is an amazing place
a place that allah subhan allah ta'ala
described in local Allah Kelly mentioned
to us in many verses in the Quran
nickname and the prophet muhammad
sallallahu silliman mention is hadi it
is enough said that the profile a solo
selling me says a loss is added to the
mle mariupol ahaha wanna come be my shop
I had prepared for my watches servants
well I always had seen nanny said hello
well not even among can contemplate and
imagine imagine a place that sometimes
you dream of so beautiful so amazing in
a so gorgeous and then as much as the
imagine of that place a lot saying to
you the paradox is even my son the very
perilous is even better so you could sit
down and imagine the unimaginable you
can sit down and think of this place of
rivers flowing from beneath it beautiful
palaces made out of gold and silver and
imagine these fellows is so big so
humongous a lie saying to you whatever
you imagined off the parable is even
nicer the third was even better the
Prophet Muhammad SAW mawari or salami
says in this honey la MOLLE of Sultan
congenita phenomena Dounia turrill Mafia
if you place a stick in my paradise the
area and space that stick had occupied
in the pyramids it's better than this
whole world and what's in it so you
could imagine you know like if you want
to say a square mirror in the parable
it's better than this entire world and
what's in it what's in the perilous
beautiful gardens beautiful trees
beautiful palaces as the profile a
cilantro salami says Palace is made out
of the normal
that we have they paid twenty cents for
but palaces made bricks bricks out of
gold and silver bricks made out of gold
and silver can you can you conceive and
comprehend a palace made out of bricks
on gold and silver this is what Allah
prepared for the people who obey Him and
worshipping this is what lots of help I
debate for the righteous people in the
paradise rivers flowing from beneath it
a lot of Hamilton Anna had described not
only that but you live in there forever
and ever and ever you don't have to
think about you getting older you don't
have to think about you getting ill
dinner together think about you getting
fatigued and tired a lot of Hannah Tyler
had prepared free in the parables and
ever and ever affinity and eternal life
in a perilous so this is the abode of
the people of the paradise and obviously
as much as we talk about the perilous we
would never speak about the reality of
it and rushed the reality of it until we
in to eat the escolar zildjian to make
us from amongst us the enter the
perilous Manila shake tell us now the
flip side to that I really obviously all
of us want to enter the paradise so we
want to do the best that we can to
please our Creator before we meet our
crater but now for the flip side just we
got a couple more minutes before we go
to break tell us for those people who
transgress the limits now they set up
partners with God you know they do
things that this please God there's a
place called hell fire we want to avoid
it so maybe some people get a little bit
you know more motivated to avoid a place
when they know a little bit more about
it can you tell us about the Hellfire we
got two minutes so now going back to the
fifth side will I other bulova asked a
lot to protect us from it it is the
Hellfire a place that a loss of hello
Darla had prepared for those who dis
abating does it is believed in it does
it transgressed those you did the bed
and evil actions a place where people
will enter they'll be punished day and
night they should never leave each time
they die they should come back a lot and
then die and come back a lot and then
body they come back a lot and then by
Allah subhana Allah will burn and
torture them in a Hellfire for the
transgression for their evil doings and
the problem muhammad sallallahu services
in the Hereafter
when I was a panel to Isla judges people
in here after the whole fire should be
dragged by 70,000 chains on every chain
70,000 angel imagine it and it's burning
and blazing and it's boiling has got a
head that will speak and what does it
say it says ya allah almighty allah i
shal torture and burn and punish those
in surveyed you those who transgressed
as you turned against you those who
neglected you let's stay Hellfire the
Prophet Mohammed Salim re or selling me
says that the lowest and the minimum and
the smallest punishment in the Hellfire
is a man that shall stand on two rocks
or fire until his brain boils but can
you imagine that not that I want you to
imagine that but how hot it is and
enough said that a prophet saw said let
me say that the foyer the hottest fire
of this world is only one out of 70 of
the Hellfire in a year after which means
the hole fire in the hereafter is hotter
than the hottest fire of this world
seventy times so this is a place for
those who disobey Allah disbelieve in
Allah so asked a lot is the rejected
makers from does you never enter the
whole fire and as you enter the paradise
we're going to go to break shake and
we're going to be right back with more
all the way from Australia here on the D
show be right back so put who Allah who
say he lost one God is one the maker of
mankind exactly a lot was somewhat lost
self-sufficient he doesn't need food or
drink he doesn't need to rest on the
seventh day ok I really had a problem
with that even before I knew anything
about a slump God resting sounds like a
week guy yeah lamb ya lit well I'm you
let he begets not he doesn't have any
children nor is he a child or born of
anything or anyone
well lemme akula hug before I and there
is nothing called eat or comparable to
him at all nobody nothing Jesus you know
nobody nobody is comparable to the
crater nothing yeah and that right there
was in his essence what I believe
naturally
jihad often mistranslated as holy war
the word jihad means to struggle Islam
does not preach violence it does not
preach vicious holy war it certainly
does not condone terror and suicide
bombing Islam preaches compassion
tolerance and justice find the truth
about Islam call toll-free 877 why Islam
order your free copy of the Koran today
back here on the Dean show and we just
spoke a little bit about in the
beginning Jesus's message Moses's
Abraham's the last and final message
center mankind apartmani peace be upon
him they all call people to a believable
message which is to worship one God they
gave glad tidings recovered of the
beautiful rewards of delights of
paradise you do good you live a good
life and then for the Hitler's of the
world right you have the Hellfire those
who transgress the limits and that's
complete justice and tell us now
speaking of death we have a young
brother 15 years old son el
methodologies been on the program before
and he's also now someone that many of
the detail fans know about we have some
sad news and we wanted to for the family
get your advice now because the doctors
they have diagnosed that he's medically
dead he went into cardiac arrest and his
his uh basically his brain is dead so
now he's breathing through a tube too
and so now if the doctors have
determined that he's medically dead they
done to all the test two MRIs there's no
blood going to the brain it's totally
dead what are you doing the situation
she obviously first of all that it's
very sad to hear what's up meet our
brother my loss panel to Allah give him
quick remedy and any and recovery and
milazzo to give his parents patience you
see brother Eddie this world is a world
of tests a lots of hair analysis when
leather moto a Italian no akuma akuma
sauna
Allah is on the credit death I'd love to
taste you to see her other Vista lures
we need to acknowledge and accept the
fact that this world is full of
challenges full of obstacles full of
hardships analyze that were not created
that to see does he obey Him even
through the moments of hardships and
does he have patience when police say
and those he disobey Him in turn away
from him and that's why I know bits of
arson and says something and this is a
chihuahua to the family maybe early
success something amazing our German
layer green movement the character and
the matter of the believer is amazing in
a server to server a Chicago Pagano hey
Lola will Allah Allah grants him
something good and beneficial what does
he do he thanks a lot as I was at Fort
Wayne our summer to da summer of a kind
of halo left and when her when harm
befalls him what does the believe it he
has patience for the sake of Allah so
when harm befalls me whither with me
myself or someone from what close family
members then a lot of her time was to
see how patient i am her patient I have
someone for the sake of Allah is older
and that's why in the recent mass I was
amazed to that character of the believer
then when something good comes teen
years he thinks a lot as I wasn't 40 and
was something harmful before z he has
patience for the sake of Allah then the
professor services well my daddy kane le
monde make this type of character that
something good comes team he thanked so
lovely something helpful before z yes
patient lives on says this is the
character of the believer and only
believer so these are the terms of a
lotta such tests us through our souls
through our children and a loss of panel
to either wants to see one thing and
brother any one thing what's your
reaction what's your reaction of allah
azzawajal test you with you shop with
your family what do you do when the
prophet muhammad sallallahu sanga one
when the profile is a lot of a salon saw
an elderly woman who breathing and
crying over the death of his son it
probably is great so the problem stood
beside there and he said have patience
so she tell him and she said leave me
alone either know what hit me and strike
me so let me sauce on a motorway so the
campaign is from fossil
reaction of this woman towards the
Prophet SAW center so they told that you
know you just spoke briefly to the
profile a start so now not knowing that
it was a prophet I'll seller says she
were looking for the profile ace a lot
was seeking his forgiveness anyway this
unsub said something very very important
he said in the muscle and the
submandibular patients at the beginning
of your reaction what do you do when you
first hear about this bad news what
what's your reaction when you are
striped with these bad news do you say
in early lower in the la-di-da job I
accept almost distant and decree upon me
or you react civilian you react
aggressively they don't accept what most
Hannah Tyler had written upon so we say
to the family have patience and sharma
and almost panel tonight shallower would
you according to a patient and at the
same time know that everything's in the
hands of Allah almost panel Tyler is the
one that gives remedy and recovery a lot
of soldiers don't want that grants life
and a lot of how I was the one that
grants day and everything's in the hands
of a las panel Tana they were asked a
larger to give you could recover being
in love tell us shake how it before we
go how important is it because many of
the dis young young boy he's 15 years
old and many of the youth nowadays
they're taking their health and they're
taking their you for granted so you see
them running towards doing bad things
instead of running towards pleasing
their creators so they're running
towards the nightclubs fornication you
know alcohol drugs and deaf can come at
any time so in short how point how
important is it because obviously you
know you go to the graveyard and you
have young old tall short i mean people
dying from all walks of life so can we
heat from this example no these two
things in life one we nine hundred
percent the other within that one
hundred percent what we know is old
that'll birth but we don't know what is
our date of death we know when we were
born but no one knows where they gonna
toy and that's why I maybe saw a body or
sudden he says take advantage of five
before five and then he says take
advantage of your life before you did
and then he says take advantage of your
young days before you get oh now you're
young you're energetic utilize that to
the pleasure of a lot is over
utilize that to achieve better in your
life utilize that to build a better
future utilize that to expand your pair
of us and reduce from your hellfire
utilize that to get closer that lots of
hannah montana before time ends and
guest pass and you don't even realize
that time went so quick that from being
fifteen year under 55 or been fifteen
you know you did so take advantage of
what my eyes only given you know you're
a lot you're energetic you could go
you're running come you got all this
power mg used to the pleasure of Allah
did not use it against the Los panel to
Anna because at the end of the day every
single one of us should regret and Allah
calls upon the believers when is that
time they gonna wake up say I'm not
gonna wake up now Windham if I'm not
gonna wake up now then we're all gonna
wake up some my brother on my sister
wake up the shop and turns are lots of
Hannibal tyla before it's too late
because once it's too late then that
moment attends that a lot giving you you
can't get it anymore shake thank you
very much for finding time to be with us
here on the Dean show God willing we can
have you back up again sometime it will
be my absolute pleasure in soma thank
you may we started with peace we have a
piece Salaam alaikum peace be with you
or alaikum assalaam and just like a love
letter to yourself and to the respectful
news i meanwe up and that was our
special guest all the way from Australia
that's right forgets for the little
technical difficulties we had with the
sound now we talked about the oneness of
the creator and it's just is just common
sense one is one no additives or
preservatives leave it alone Jesus
called people to worship one guy he
never call people to worship himself
Jesus was sent by God and he ate and he
slept and he prayed to God that means he
was a messenger of god nothing more
nothing less but one who called you away
from the Hellfire Jesus did and towards
the paradise and to the purpose of life
and you got that all encapsulated in
Islam so Islam is the belief and all the
messages of God including Mohammad being
the last and to really take this life
seriously it's a test and that's why the
Quran was sent so we need to get to know
this book the Quran so we can live by
understand it and so we could pass the
time
of life and at the end we can be
successful and you won't find any other
book out there in the world making the
astonishing claims as the Quran does
that is indeed from the crater the
crater identifies himself Allah in
Aramaic Allahu Allahu this is the one
God that Jesus called upon and it's very
important that we really really really
take the matter seriously and we also
reminded people through the example of
this young brother son el who's a 15
years old and you can see right now that
he's been classified as medically dead
and this can happen to anybody you know
who's guaranteeing you tomorrow the only
thing you're guaranteed for tomorrow is
def that you're all going to die you can
have it today you can have it tomorrow
we can happen next month it can happen
to second so be prepared by doing good
living a good wholesome life and there's
nothing in Islam in this way of life
from the crater that goes against your
very nature that's against humanity as a
whole everything in it is good cause you
the good and at the end you live a good
wholesome life but then you got paradise
you got paradise so many benefits and
all these benefits are for you to
benefit from in Islam get to know it
call us at 1 866 to Islam we'll see you
next time God willing until then peace
be unto you